thank you for having me here just a
little bit about my
my name is Ian Rose my background is as
a geologist but after finishing up my
grad work and geology I sort of jumped
ship on that and joined the Berkeley
data Berkeley Institute for a data
science or bintz and during my time
there
I've been working on projects around the
project Jupiter ecosystem but primarily
on Jupiter lab which is what I'm going
to be telling you about today
so the overall motivation for project
Jupiter as a whole is to build is to
build the tools that we need for doing
interactive computation with
human-in-the-loop computation which is
something that traditionally hasn't been
a sort of respectable field in computer
science but for science and data science
it turns out that's a really essential
thing to do to be able to you know write
a little code inspect the results maybe
get some rich outputs and so one of the
things sort of the thing that really
made project Jupiter take off was in
2012 we released the ipython notebook I
wasn't on the project at that time but
you can sort of see that it has a lot of
the familiar features that you would be
familiar with from the Jupiter notebook
there are input cells there are outputs
there's rich rich rendered output and it
became popular beyond I think really
anybody's expectations I checked last
night and as of as of then there are
over 3 million notebooks publicly
available on github really astonishing
number we have some indication from the
folks who work at github that there are
a roughly similar amount of private
notebooks so this is a tool that's
become extremely widely used and I
suspect there are a lot of users in the
audience right now
since that initial release we've had a
couple of really sort of high-profile I
guess you could call them victories but
for open science so this is the this is
the central plot from the LIGO
experiment the thing that detected
gravitational waves there are a number
of features in this plot that people who
are familiar with the PI data ecosystem
would recognize these plots were
generated in matplotlib that color scale
that's being cut off at the bottom there
is various that color scale was
developed by people who used to sit next
to me in the office to found under vault
and Nathaniel Smith and then when they
publish this they actually published a
series of notebooks that allow you to
run the exact same analysis and discover
gravitational waves for yourself and
this this effort won the Nobel Prize in
Physics last year and so that was very
exciting to see and to see our tools you
know the PI data ecosystem broadly our
tools being used for such a cool project
we're also being used in open economics
this is a blog post that Paul Romer
wrote I don't remember when but it was
relatively recently Paul Romer you may
recognize that name he won the pseudo
Nobel Prize in Economics a few weeks ago
and did a bunch of foundational work in
macroeconomic modelling of technological
changes and he's been a big booster of
ours for a while in terms of advocate
advocating for open economics open
research and publishing your data and
code and he thinks that Jupiter is a big
part of it despite these successes the
classic Jupiter notebook inner foot
interface has sort of started to show
its age you know it started with with
notebooks those became very popular but
then people started to ask well you know
these notebooks are nice but what if I
want to open other files as well so we
made a file file browser view in the
notebook server and they said okay
that's really great but like you know
there's there's only so far I can go
with the notebook sooner or later I'm
going to need a
they patch to go for a - you know shell
out to bash so we also added a terminal
to the front end so you can you know
open up a bash terminal and run all
through your you're familiar bash
commands and then people said well you
know again notebooks are nice but
sometimes there's no substitute for a
text file so we also added a text editor
and all these things are they exist in
the classic notebook interface today I
don't know the answer this but just out
of curiosity is anybody surprised that
these things are in the classic notebook
interface yeah they're kind of hidden
there a few hands went up not not
everybody but a few they're kind of
hidden they're not particularly popular
features I think despite their I think
they're clear usefulness
they are sort of bolted on to the
interface in a not very well thought out
manner that basically follows their
evolution so we wanted to address this
and also to sort of revamp the Jupiter
or the Jupiter notebook interface the
notebook was written in 2011 2012 you
may or may not be aware but the web has
changed a lot since then it was written
using the tools of 2011 so we wanted to
come up with take all the lessons that
we learned in building the notebook
interface and apply them towards and the
the next step so to that end our goals
were to build the components for
interactive computing in a really
flexible and integrated manner so that
people can do different spins on them
they can extend them easily they can mix
and match in different ways we also
wanted to do to use modern JavaScript
development this this project Jupiter
lab is prime is primarily written in
typescript which if you haven't come
across that that's JavaScript with type
annotations it's you know once you start
working with type annotations it's
really hard to go back it really cuts
down on a whole class of errors so in
addition to plugging typescript I would
also really recommend looking into the
Python typing
it really it really smoothes out a lot
of development I'm a big fan we use NPM
and yarn everything is bundled together
with web pack and then we are using well
one of if not the most popular web
frameworks for a lot of the UI stuff
it's funny a year or so ago there was
essentially no react in our code base
primarily because react had a kind of
scary
non open-source license attached to it
and then you may or may not have heard
that Facebook relicense react and pretty
much immediately people started writing
stuff in reactants so now it's all over
our code base we also have really
focused on having a clean modelview
separation between the sort of internal
state of a notebook document and then
what you see on the page what that
allows us to do is have dues for do neat
tricks like have multiple views of the
same file at the same time it allows us
to have one source of truth for the data
the data that you see on the page it
really cleans up a lot of stuff we work
hard to make this a high-performance
interface and to have a well-thought-out
user experience we've actually done some
UX UI testing which for a project that
comes out of academic science that's
that's not particularly common and then
these last two points I want to dwell on
a bit we work really hard we've we've
worked really hard to have to make a
strong distinction between our private
and our public API and the reason we
want to do that is because we want
everybody in the ecosystem to actually
start to scratch their own itches with
this we want people to write extensions
and target our api's and you know and
because basically the whole community
can generate much more and much cooler
stuff than we can as a relatively small
team and so so we want people to use our
public public API if they're not working
for you we want to hear about it the old
notebook interface had basically no
public API s and people just have
do we add it and it has become sort of a
unmaintainable state of affairs so but
here we're really writing with
extensibility in mind and to that extent
we're trying to dog food this as much as
we can so the entire application that
you're about to see is a collection of
Jupiter lab extensions so if you write
an extension it is on completely equal
footing with all the stuff that we write
so the the overall framework is
everything is an extension write your
own and it's on equal footing with ours
so this is a screenshot of it which I'm
not going to dwell on because I'm gonna
show you a demo in a moment so today
we've been developing this project for
about three and a half years we have
about a hundred and seventy contributors
it's got over 13,000 commits uh-huh
3,700 releases there's a reason that
that number is so absurdly large and
that's because we have 60 core
components to this project so every time
we make a release we actually make
roughly 60 releases so divide that 3700
by 60 and you have maybe a more
reasonable number of releases we've made
it's got full support for the same
notebooks that you've been working on
for however long you've been working on
them it's the same file format so you
can open the exact same notebook with
the classic interface or with this new
interface and everything should work the
same
we've got notebooks terminals text
editors a file browser code consoles a
lot of the stuff that existed in the old
interface but in a sort of well in
better integrated manner yeah you can
you can read the rest oh there's an
important point at the bottom there we
want people to start using this we're
out of beta give it a shot kick the
tires let us know what you think we're
going to lead in the next couple months
we're gonna try to message this a lot
more but it's ready for use please use
it
who is using Jupe Jupe lab there's a big
ol list of things that is running off
the end of the page so I won't dwell on
this too much except for the first one
I'm going to dwell in a little bit
because I think it's really cool so at
left LSST stands for the see if I can
remember this the large synoptic survey
telescope it is one of if not the
biggest ground-based telescopes that's
currently being built it's gonna be
deployed in the in the Chilean Andes and
it will be let's see it will be
surveying the whole southern sky once
every three days something like that and
that's going to be generating 20
terabytes of data per night and so this
is something that is I think that
qualifies this truly large data and one
of the things that this community
overall has learned in recent years is
that for data that big we want the
compute to come to the data rather than
the other way around we don't want to
SCP around 20 terabytes of data every
day
so the LSST has chosen jupiter lab as
their interface for accessing this data
and they're building all sorts of really
cool tooling around Jupiter lab for how
they're going to analyze this data and
there's a there's a screenshot of their
particular spin on Jupiter lab ok so now
I'm gonna try to do a live demo see how
well it works can everybody see that is
that an appropriate soom level okay so
this is the overall interface we've got
a file browser on the left hand side
here there's a list of running sessions
running notebooks we have a command
palette with a bunch of commands you can
execute a list of open tabs which is not
very much right now there's this fun new
extension manager oops so let's get
going with a notebook so I'm going to
open this this demo of the Lorenz
differential equations and if I
run a few cells I get this nice Lorenz
attractor has anybody ever found it
challenging to if you have some
interactive or complex output that you
always having to scroll up and down to
the code that generates it that can be
really annoying so one of our favorite
new features is - is the ability to
create a new view for the output and
this breaks out this output area into a
separate tab and now I have this sort of
pseudo dashboard where I can do these
sliders and change the parameters of the
Lorenz attractor we also have the
ability to open the same open a new view
on the same file so if I right click on
this notebook and open a new view for it
now I have this open notebook open it's
the same notebook open twice so I can do
things like change and it's updated
automatically
oh there's also dragging and dropping of
cells so if I drag this so over here now
I've dragged between - yeah really the
same notebook so it's a little odd to
have done that but it makes more sense
when you have two different notebooks
open okay so the notebooks you all know
them over there but we also have lots of
other things so I'm going to open a
launcher and make a new text file I'm
gonna rename this too so I'm gonna make
a markdown file and we're gonna say this
is a tutorial for how to use Python but
because markdown is a first-class
citizen
in Jupiter lab we can open a view of
this in markdown and start editing
and that having code snippets here okay
so again one of our goals is to have the
components of this as reusable as
possible and as mixed as Mashable as
possible so one of the things that that
we frequently hear from people is that
they really like Jupiter kernels but the
notebook interface itself is maybe a
little too heavy they prefer to work in
text files a lot of times I prefer to
work in text files there are simpler
formats so one of the things we can do
is use a text file but I can create a
console for this text file and I make
this console is gonna be a Python 3
console and one once this console is
created for this text file I can now
press shift enter in this Python code
block and it'll execute in the console
and show and show me the outputs there
and so we can do other things so now I
can start actually making maybe a blog
post about how to make a plot
and if that worked I should then be able
to embed that in up there we go
and so I've created this plot and now
your your documentation doesn't have to
go out of date just because you changed
something we can generate this plot and
then embed it all in the same file okay
so that's live editing of markdown
documents so out of the box we have a
bunch of different file formats that you
know how to read obviously notebooks are
in there text text plain text files are
in there we can also do things but
that's what that one's not very
interesting that's the one we just made
we also have image editors I'm going to
close some stuff or not image editors
but image viewers so here's a view from
Hubble here's an image from Hubble we
also have native support for Vega and
Vega lite documents so here's a here's a
Vega plot underneath the underneath the
hood this Vega plot is just JSON so
here's another view on the exact same
plot but using a text editor and so and
because we still have the same live data
model that underlies both these views on
the file I can say change this from a
bar plot to a circle plot it should
update don't change it back to a bar
because it looks better let's see so
those are things that are built in what
else is built in we've got a
high-performance csv viewer here's the
iris data one of the really cool things
about this csv viewer is that it was
engineered to within an inch of its life
so it actually is extremely high
performance it can render it can render
CSVs of well it can basically render
arbitrarily large CSVs
it you will run out of browser memory
before it will stop being able to render
it because it does lazy lazy loading and
lazy rendering so I'm gonna actually to
try to pull off a demo here so I've got
a sis
CSV here which is 1.2 million rows and
I'm gonna try to open it in LibreOffice
the same thing will work in calc
so okay and it's we're gonna let it sit
there for a while you can see it a
progress bar down there and I'm gonna
try to navigate to the same data over
here if I can remember where it is
here it is
which one is it I don't want to exit I
want the full one okay and we're we're
live and we can we can scroll Scroll
scroll Scroll scroll there's one point
one six million rows of data and
eventually this will finish
maybe not oh there it goes okay so the
data grid is neat it's not very
interactive yet we have we have great
plans for it but right now it does some
pretty good flips it's in pretty good
rendering let's see what else is neat
we've got here's a here's an example of
an extension this is there's an
extension that we have written that is
not installed in the base package but
that allows you to render geo JSON files
a lot of people are working with geo
JSON these days it's really a nice web
friendly format for for geographic data
so here is a geo JSON that I downloaded
the other day that has the rights of way
for all the LA metro train systems so
this is again if I open it with a text
editor is just text that describes this
but when we open it with the geo JSON
viewer it opens it in a tab with a live
map and so we can figure out where we
are which is down here does anybody take
the expo line over here this morning yay
I take the 754 what else there are PDF
viewers we have viewers for FASTA which
is a biologic genomics data type there
are viewers for well lots of things so
they're escaping me right now but lots
of lots of user contributed viewers at
this point okay I think that's most of
this Oh isn't here here's a couple of
huh I'm gonna go into this one because I
like this one and I wrote it this is a
github viewer for for Jupiter lab so we
can type in a username this is going to
the Jupiter lab organization and then go
to maybe the the Jupiter lab media
repository so I'm browsing github right
now this is a repository that we have to
storing some of our documentation and
some of our tutorial materials so
I can open up this and sort of have let
let the documentation give a tutorial
for me while I stand here again this is
not locally on machine on my machine
this is pulling it from github you can
see there's also Google Drive
integration that you can just install
there's a whole saga that I won't get
into about that okay so that's the
overall Jupiter lab interface so maybe
some of you have never seen that before
maybe some of you have so this is a
little this is a something for the
people who have maybe tried Jupiter lab
maybe they tried it a year ago and it
was unless far less polished of a state
and didn't like it so this is to try to
get you to give it another shot if you
if you haven't yet so we've got a lot
more extensions in the last few months
if you were in the previous talk in this
session there was a nice nice example of
the bouquet desk dashboarding and that's
recently landed in jupiter lab so we've
got a here's a screenshot that we saw a
live version of that earlier there are
different there's the ability to add
different themes so here are here's two
screenshots of the same same view but
with it with a light theme and a dark
theme those are the themes that we ship
automatically but users can write their
own themes there we now have these
workspace and tree handlers which is a
little subtle but I think it's a really
important use case this allows us to
point to files and specific activity
layouts in Jupiter lab via via a URL and
so if you want to share something with
somebody you can construct a URL that
will open all the right files open all
the right activities and really get them
off and running quickly we now have the
ability to hook up kernel completions
and text files so that so you know if
you have if you ever feel like you're
missing tab completion now it's there
there's persistent collapsing of cells a
better design menu system you can now
blow up and decrease the font size and
note notebooks and text files and if I
were more organized I would have done
that here so that certain other UI
elements weren't as blown up and there's
the fun new user interface for managing
third-party extensions so I'm gonna hop
back to my live demo here here is the
list of extensions that I currently have
installed in this application if I go
down here this is actually going out to
the Internet and searching for other
extensions that we can install into the
application so one of the fun things I
like to do is one of our tutorial one of
our tutorials for create creating an
extension is something that adds a
random xkcd comic into your Drupal lab
interface and so what I'd like to do is
check and see how many have made that
extension and then published it so we
currently have looks like about a dozen
people have published xkcd extensions to
NPM so in case you've ever wanted to try
a dozen versions of the exact same thing
you can try that okay so that's where
the application stands today there are a
few neat things that we have on the
horizon that are sort of more in the
planning stages but if you're interested
in them by all means come talk to me and
or maybe even contribute to them one
thing that I'm very excited about is the
ability to interact with large remote
datasets so we saw with that CSV example
that I opened that was about a 200
megabyte CSV that's about the largest
file that you can reasonably load in a
browser tab but clearly a lot of people
here work regularly work with files that
are much larger than that and we want to
build in some native tooling that allows
us to more easily inspect these that
allows us to gifts and maybe some code
snippets for how to load them and just
really smooth out the process of loading
really large data sets
so we're looking at you know like hdf5
datasets netcdf datasets which are
really common in oceanography and
atmospheres where the cloud are
optimized Geo Tiff's and then there's
the old workhorse of CSV so we want to
be able to load and inspect larger and
larger CSVs I have a this is something I
was I was trying to get working and kind
of got it working so I'll show it this
was this was my project last night so
here's here's sort of some of my initial
experimentations in loading cloud
optimized Geo Tiff's each of these Geo
Tiff's are on a live map and each of
them is about a gigabyte and because geo
Tiff's are a well specified format and
are able to be loaded on things like s3
as static files we can actually do some
streaming of the datasets so you can see
it's good as I'm zooming in it's getting
sharper and sharper and so with with
streaming techniques like this we can
start to we can start to do some clever
things with large datasets so that's
what we're looking at here is some of
the flooding due to Hurricane Harvey
this one which is failing to load was of
some of the fires that were in Santa
Rosa last year lots of really fun and
horrible national natural disasters to
investigate this one's a little more fun
this is a volcanic crater near Mammoth
it's really nice out there it's also an
active volcano so this could be a future
disaster site
so I come from a background of open
science and open data so we're you know
basically everything I ever do I push to
github and you know in open repositories
but I've been told that in certain
financial or medical contexts there is
such a thing as sensitive data so we're
working on building out some of the
tools for people who do have to deal
with sensitive data things like equip
ssin and auditing and role based
accesses so that institutions that do
need to work with that will get some
tools out of the box with Jupiter and
then the sort of the Big Kahuna this is
something that we've had a number of
false starts on is real-time
collaboration we're working on it
hopefully within a year or so we'll have
something usable for people to actually
stand up at Jupiter hub instance and
actually allow their users to
collaborate in real time on documents
and to indicate real time collaboration
I have put up two versions of the same
screenshot there are some more features
that were working on that I'm not going
to go into in any detail but they're
here so by all means talk to me if you
want to hear more about them and this is
definitely not just my project this is a
large effort with dozens and hundreds of
people some of them are listed here also
some funding sources and thanks for
listening
and it looks like I have plenty time for
questions
yeah so so this is we have an
unfortunate naming collision in that we
refer to note we say we use the word
notebook for both the file format and
the application that's now we're trying
to encourage everybody to say the
notebook is the file format those are
the exact same we have a new interface
for reading those files the same files
where it will work in either interface
the old application will be deprecated
yeah so Jupiter yes so Jupiter hub is is
complimentary to this and is there is
there anything in particular it's very
much alive and is it supports multiple
users very well what it doesn't support
as multiple users editing the same file
at the same time yeah I mean we're
definitely it is more of an IDE than the
old notebook interface so to that extent
yes like it it is it is an IDE as for
specific features they you know it's
still a web application it's still not
as fully featured just something like vs
code might be or you know and any of the
other desktop IDs but we're moving in
that direction yeah
[Applause]
it's not right now that without their
there there was somebody who was on our
team who has since who has since left
for higher paying jobs um who who was
working on that that's the type of thing
that would that in general there's a
couple overlapping but distinct issues
with that there's there's a mark down
has a quasi stable citation format but
it's not clear that it's widely
supported enough for us to use it we may
eventually end up biting the bullet and
adding these some citation support to
the note book format but we don't I
don't think there's a there's not really
a good story there right now something
people want though
right now it's fairly crude there's a
collapse here here and I can click on it
and it just hides it we may start
building that out a little bit more to
have things like different contexts in
different contexts that will show
different things like you suggested but
right now it's not there yeah there
yes OMB dime has a lab extension I
haven't checked on it recently but it
should last time I checked it worked
yeah so the so part of one of the whole
motivations of jus Perl AB is to have so
all these MD extensions that the classic
nope nope notebook has they are they're
all using not officially supported API
is they're sort of a nightmare to
maintain one of the whole motivations
here is to have a very public official
way to make extensions so currently
existing extensions will need to be
ported they're not compatible but the
idea is to have ultimate so it's kind of
annoying for current extension authors
but the idea is ultimately to have a
better supportive extension ecosystem
yeah it's really hard you get people on
github who like you know are who can be
very angry and be like this this is
obviously the best you know workflow
this is I can't imagine why you would
ever want to do anything different for
this I was like well no there's lots of
people who have lots of different use
cases that I don't think I have a good
answer
it's community management and it's hard
yeah
so this will run into similar problems
like for for loading for loading
documents into memory we're kind of
limited by order a couple hundred
megabytes that's that's about the
biggest you can reasonably do otherwise
you'll start running into troubles and
we again we want to build out some of
the tooling around interacting with
larger data sets but it's not there yet
yeah
and in a real-time collaboration setting
I think both are very common you know
some people it depends on the context in
which people are working like sometimes
their notebooks are not public right and
they will they will be working on some
internal Jupiter hub deployment from my
work it's all open on github so I tend
to have a more get github oriented
workflow both are valid
the idea would be to have something
that's much more akin to Google Docs
where you're editing the same file at
the same time and there's a
sophisticated and very difficult to code
algorithm set of algorithms that can
handle conflicts when they arise as they
inevitably do when people are editing
but at the same time yeah there there is
something that will warn you if you if
if it has changed on disk if for
instance somebody else is editing the
same file it's kind of crude right now
and hopefully will become a non-problem
if we have real-time collaboration up
and running so in Jupiter labs
specifically that's something that is on
our to-do list like we would love to be
able to say hey print this specific tab
and not this tab not like the whole HTML
page but one of the one of the panes in
the interface it's not there right now
so in order to print a notebook from
Jupiter lab you'd probably want to save
it as or export it to like a PDF or
something and then print that yeah
was that no there you can have an
arbitrary number of kernels running at
the same so if I you know open all these
see all these these okay
see all these all these have a green dot
each of those dots indicates a running
kernel those are all separate kernels so
but they can also share kernels if you
like so you can wire up two notebooks to
the same kernel which may or may not be
advise it but okay I think we're just
about there so thanks for listening
[Applause]